so the hero [ __ ] of entrepreneurship
of like i almost grind myself down
i'm a [ __ ] hero working super hard
i'm doing it right and it's such
[ __ ] and it's such a toxic aspect of
all work and i hate it but i definitely
worked 110 hour weeks for like months
ground myself down to the point of deep
misery and there is no
quicker way
to hate a thing you love
that than to work like to work on it
like that right like i really love
coffee i definitely got to the point
where i was like i should quit coffee i
should just i hate this i hate this i
hate my life i hate working in this i
should just do something else because i
worked in a stupid way and i burnt
myself out physically and emotionally
because people do that because the world
says good for you get the grind on you
know i mean what it's your thing it's
yours pull yourself into it you're like
no don't don't do that that's really bad
what you should do is start with enough
capital that you can hire people to work
with you pay them properly
and then work in a healthy manner do you
know i mean like just have work and home
uh be separate that's helpful turn off
don't work at weekends or don't work
some days a week it's very satisfying
early doors to pour yourself into a
business it is rewarding it's enjoyable
but
you're just burning through yourself so
fast and so i regret not starting with
probably twice as much money hiring more
people out the gate and going home at
five o'clock hey friends welcome back to
deep dive if you're new here my name is
ali and in each episode i chat to
entrepreneurs creators authors and other
inspiring people about how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools that can help us along our shared
journey of living healthier happier more
productive lives now many of us dream
about turning our passion or hobby into
a business but very few of us manage to
successfully do it and at least keep it
fun while we're doing it one person who
seems to really nailed it is world
barista champion author creator james
hoffman who is one of the most famous
people in the world when it comes to
coffee he's got his own coffee shop he's
got his own coffee roasters he's got his
own youtube channel with 1.2 million
subscribers he has hundreds of thousands
of followers across all the other social
media platforms he's written a
best-selling coffee themed book and in
this episode we talk a lot about how
he's managed to build this empire themed
around this passion this hobby of coffee
we talk a bit about how to actually
build a bricks and mortars like physical
goods coffee roastery type business
completely from scratch and we talk a
little bit about james's regrets when it
comes to hustling and burnout i
definitely enjoyed the conversation we
could have talked for hours and hours
more because there was so much more to
unpack in james story so we're
definitely going to have him on for a
part two at some point but in the
meantime i hope you enjoyed this
conversation between me and james
hoffman i want to understand how how how
do we get here how did you end up
becoming the world's most famous coffee
person on the internet i don't think i
can say i'm the world's most famous
coffee person i think howard schultz
still will maintain like higher howard
schultz never heard of it
you know there's james hoffman and then
there's like i don't i don't know anyone
else in the coffee world to be honest so
you're in a category of one as far as
i'm concerned um how did this happen
it's a it's a good question i think um
so i've been in coffee since 2003
okay most people starting coffee for the
same reason which is sort of great how
how old were you in 2003 have you done
my house uh 22-23 22-23 yeah okay so i'm
i'm like how old am i now i'm 42 now
okay i think about it so at the age of
like 23 yeah you got into coffee got
into coffee what were you doing before
23. oh i worked as a croupier in casinos
a croupier what's a creepy uh you deal
casino games so if you go gambling yep
in the the bowtie and the nonsense i
would do that um did you go to
university i did go to university for no
real good reason
[Laughter]
i have a combined arts degree in um
philosophy
central and east european area studies
and east asian studies
okay from durham university which which
gives me the extra letters on the end
yeah wait what extra letters you get
that you get the ba ons done elm so oh
yeah like oxford cambridge and durham
can tab right oh yeah until i get a dun
out for no good reason nice i thought
that was like a furniture company no
one's it is i think
it's okay no one's ever asked to see my
degree i i don't regret going to
university i should not have gone to
university okay i gained nothing other
than debt and weight uh that was my i
had good and friends and life experience
all that stuff but academically yeah
total waste of time after university
were you like i have this combined arts
degree in philosophy and stuff what am i
doing with my life totally there was a
job demonstrating domestic coffee
machines in a house of fraser department
store that paid weekly and um you know
paid six pounds an hour uh and i was
like whatever i don't drink coffee like
how hard can it be and so uh i got this
job
and what i've always done it's a sort of
weird sickness for me is whatever i've
worked in
i've tried to kind of read up upon so
when i worked as a crew pa i got really
into like the history of card shopping
and and kind of a little bit of magic
stuff cheating at cards sorry card
shopping is the sort of broad term and
um this is a really interesting history
around that anyway uh coffee same thing
i started buying whatever books i could
find about coffee uh and i read a couple
that just
really interested me um there's a book
called the devil's cup that's kind of
essentially about coffee's journey from
ethiopia as it spread throughout the
whole world and it was kind of the way
it infects and binds itself into
different cultures just really
interested me i was like coffee's way
more interesting than i thought it's not
just nescafe that was my kind of limit
of understanding and so i decided i
would learn to drink coffee and i did
and i just sort of fell in love with it
and i tried to work in wine when i was a
little bit younger sort of university
time and just sort of hated that
industry
what was that about you that makes you
want to kind of because i imagine if
you're getting like a six quid an hour
job most people wouldn't think you know
what let me read up about the history of
coffee so i can understand it more i
don't know i mean there wasn't a lot to
do most of the time it's one part of it
and i don't know like i i've always been
a a reader yeah uh an aggressive kind of
reader and so i was like well i might as
well know what i'm talking about i
dislike
that you know i'm not a comfortable liar
or or bluffer
to a point uh and so i just you know
started reading about it and then i just
kind of fell into this rabbit hole where
it just fascinated me and i started
working my way up that company's kind of
i started doing training and teaching
for that kind of company i did
demonstrators yeah so i looked after
kind of demonstrated some like
selfridges and house phrases and all the
kind of big department stores here and
then i got a job training for a kind of
big commercial machine company rather
than domestic ones commercial like those
big ones that cost
right yeah like like like car money and
how old were you at the foot
24 okay twenty twenty four twenty five
so in about a year or two you sort of
worked your way up the house of fraser
department store hierarchy to become a
kind of demonstrator of coffee machines
yeah and then you did a sort of lateral
move to the industrial teaching people
about coffee right so i would then go
around the uk i had like a big
commercial machine in my car a projector
screen i would turn up and do these
trainings because the coffee scene in
2005 was
wasn't really there you know what i mean
it was growing and it was kind of being
fostered and there were these things
called barista competitions so i went in
my demonstrator job i'd met this guy
who was the uk bristol champion and i
didn't know that much i did know that he
would come in i would clean everything
prep it for him he would work for four
hours and then leave and i would clean
up again and he would earn more that day
than i did that week i was like tell me
more about these competitions uh
and so i got into the competition thing
and i won the uk bristol championship
what is the barista competition
it's kind of part
uh
cooking competition part sommelier
competition part dog show like you uh
dog show it's a performance right like
you're sort of assist on your
performance as well so you make um
there's four judges who your customers
and you make them each and espresso eat
your cappuccino each what's called a
signature drink which is a non-alcoholic
coffee cocktail of some sort they judge
you on your
drinks are they delicious on your
knowledge on your presentation skills
there's a couple of other people who
judge your technical skills
and the best barista in this weird game
based on coffee wins and so i competed
in 2005 one in the uk in 2006 and ended
up winning the world competition in 2007
so it was kind of
coffee so this is kind of really
important coffee was so young in some
ways at that point that a kid could come
in start drinking coffee in 2004 and be
a world breast champion in 2007. that
shouldn't be allowed right like i'm not
some sort of uh savant in the world of
coffee it just was an immature industry
that if you were willing to work hard
and and you got lucky and i got lucky
then you could sort of have these kind
of breaks
so
yeah it's kind of weird to me and
is is that a thing now like could
someone listening to this decide you
know what i'm going to become world
coffee champion in the next two years
it's so much more competitive now like
it's a much more developed thing where
you know people might train for a long
time the competitions are just much
harder the standards keep going up and
up and up
um so you know the nice thing about
winning the worlds is that they put you
out to pasture you're not allowed to
compete again so you are undefeated and
you know
it's not like every year you have to
sort of fight back and retain your title
exactly you're not you're not welcome
and that's good it's also bad in that
every year you dilute the pool of world
champions one more time uh so you you
are less interesting every year which is
kind of uh something i worked out quite
early on and and that wasn't really a
pursuit of like being a world champion
for
whatever um so in 2008 i started a
business uh okay i'm sorry can we rewind
a bit so yeah you're
doing the selling industrial coffee
machines and training people in how to
use industrial coffee machines and then
you discover that there's this thing
called the barista championships roughly
and so what was the process from from
the oh
there is a thing such as this too i'm
going to actually start competing in
this thing pretty i mean pretty short so
you know the community was very small
then so finding people who knew about
the competitions was pretty easy i began
to work with people who understood them
or judged in them or that kind of stuff
and my boss at the time was hugely
supportive of them and they were doing
work to kind of get these competitions
happening
because they saw that
if coffee boomed in the uk if you sold
commercial machines you would benefit so
their job was very much to kind of fan
the flames of getting coffee going in
the uk um so i was kind of supported
very much by that employer which is kind
of unusual uh
in some way or was back then i ended up
quitting my job
before i competed in 2007. i sort of if
you go and tell people what to do for a
long time there is a point at which you
should be like
just go and do it like stop stop pre
just go and open a coffee shop and
that's what we're going to do so myself
and my business partner we're going to
open a coffee shop in shoreditch we're
going to roast the coffee on site
and we quit our jobs and uh i was going
to compete i didn't think i would win
went to tokyo where the competition was
one that kind of ruined everything
because suddenly i had to you know this
kind of responsibilities and travel and
opportunities when you win that pushed
us back until 2008 which was kind of
good in that we were about to sign a
lease just as the the global economy
tanked and so we didn't sign a lease and
we were like this is this is just a bad
time to sign a 10-year lease um and so
we took her like a little railway arch
in in there's loads of railways so there
were cheap spaces back then in london
and we started roasting coffee there and
trying to wholesale it into london cafes
and that
worked and that you know that turned
into a whole other thing
to to what extent are independent coffee
shops concerned by the costas and the
starbucks of the world we're going to
take a very quick break to introduce our
sponsor for this episode who is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last few years and they're a
fantastic interactive platform with
online courses in maths science and
computer science my personal favorites
are the computer science courses i think
are absolutely fantastic and when i was
initially applying to med school i was
actually torn between applying to
medicine and applying to computer
science and i ended up going with
medicine in the end which i really don't
regret but there's a big part of me that
really wanted to continue learning the
stuff around computer science continuing
to understand how coding works and the
courses on brilliant have given me that
foundation in computer science which i
didn't have before the courses are
really fun engaging and interactive and
the way they teach you stuff is based on
very first principles thinking like
they'll teach you a concept and then
they'll take you through interactive
exercises to actually help solidify your
understanding of that concept and it's
pretty cool because they're always
updating the library with new courses
for example there's one they've just
released called everyday maths which is
kind of like a visual exploration of the
maths that we use in everyday life like
for example fractions and percentages
and putting them in a context that makes
it very understandable and certainly
very different to the kind of boring way
that i was taught maths when i was in
school the courses and lessons are
particularly good if you have a busy
life with lots of stuff going on because
they really teach you the stuff in
bite-sized chunks so you can always
return to a course at a later date if
you don't have time to do it in one
sitting if any of that stands up your
straight then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also going to be in the
video description and in the show notes
we'll get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
not hugely unless they're in um most
independents see other independents as
competition by and large uh they are
they are trading on the idea that you're
buying from them something of higher
quality made with better ingredients
made with more care okay koster is
trading on it's convenient and and
relatively
inexpensive yeah
you know what i mean and that's a
different audience who is prioritizing
one thing over another
um and you know independents are more
focusing on space experience
should be a nice place to go and hang
out right it's important so you want to
be in a space for an hour should be a
nice space i don't particularly enjoy
being in most chain coffee shops for an
hour i don't like the space they want me
to move on and they need me to move on
because you know we're that's part of
the business model whereas i think it's
it's kind of different in independent
businesses so as a
do you does the coffee from costco
starbucks just taste objectively worse
to you than coffee from an independent
place generally
i enjoy it less okay let's go with that
like better and worse it gets very
subjective it gets easily quite preachy
of like well this is why i think it's
bad or or judgy or those kind of things
a lot of people enjoy coffee from
starbucks
millions of people enjoy coffee or even
from mcdonald's
and the fact that i don't enjoy it is
not a reflection on them if i say it's
it's worse than what i drink that is a
reflection on them if i say i don't
enjoy it as much it's not and that's
kind of an important i think one of the
things that kind of has helped me in the
kind of uh growth on youtube is having
an attitude of like i'm not
trying to judge what you drink but if
you want it to be better i want to help
you
that's that's the kind of the vibe there
um not this is what you should drink
this is how to be correct this is what
you should order
none of that nonsense it's just no one
likes it um
so yeah i i don't enjoy it as much it's
a different product
it's just a different thing and it's
it's got a different intended sort of
target price point process
than what you would see at a good
independent okay so it sounds like i
guess with any
even with a kind of a business model i'm
more familiar with like starting a
youtube channel um
it's very hard to do unless you have a
way of differentiating differentiating
yourself in the market as it were
absolutely and even then it takes a
large amount of consistency and effort
and sticking with putting a lot of stuff
out there and not making much money for
a very long time and then once you get
that product market fit as it were you
then benefit from kind of
good things happening
yeah i think there are there are
successful coffee shops out there that
make people a good living and they enjoy
running that business but i think you've
got to want to enjoy running the
business
you know what i mean and that's that's
the bit well kind of like if you enjoy
baking you shouldn't necessarily open a
bakery because those are two very
different things absolutely and and you
know i think the best operators are
people who love hospitality and they
understand coffee's place within that as
food's place in that
you know how signage works that has a
place in the experience hospitality and
and those are the best operators to me
they're also the most profitable most
successful because they're they're kind
of the holistic operator not just the
coffee obsessive who's like i'm gonna
save the best coffee in london and then
they're kind of bummed that no one cares
because the wait is long it's not
comfortable it's not enjoyable
it's not what i need necessarily from
the coffee shop i don't need every time
i go out for coffee for it to be the
single best cup of coffee of my life
i'm often with someone i want i want
coffee as a social lubricant i want it
as a little caffeine i want it maybe
it's an intellectual experience like oh
this is interesting to taste
but you know it can't be the sole focus
of a business and i think it's taken
london coffee shops and globally coffee
shops maybe 15 years to work that out oh
yeah there's um a lot of thoughts that
are sparked through through that have
have you come across uh the e-myth oh
yeah oh big that was that was a super
early read for me so i
to go back to starting a business i was
a classic uh i was a coffee obsessive i
was like well i understand coffee i'm
good at making coffee i should open a
coffee business and uh very quickly it
was like oh
then there's the business of business
and uh how rapidly can i get good at the
business of business to build sort of
the machine underlying that and and i
didn't have time to do anything other
than read
and read i did and so yeah michael
gerber's book i think was uh super super
informative very relevant to me and
further encouragement to to work on the
business or in it uh which becomes
slightly glib when you say it but it's
so
so important yeah i can't i can't you
know what i mean i can't emphasize
enough that the need to get out from the
the the daily of the manufacturing of a
business whatever it is that you make
and sell and do into a higher level
think uh or so a thought process
to understand the model the mechanics of
them it's a machine right you're
tweaking cogs and you're kind of making
it work just nice
that's hard and you need to get good at
that and that has nothing to do with
coffee has nothing to do with coffee and
everything to do with understanding
everything from people through to sort
of marketing sales
economics finances reading a balance
sheet understanding the impacts of
decisions you make on your balance sheet
on your future on your cash flows all of
that sort of stuff
i really enjoyed it which is fortunate
uh lots of people are immediately turned
off and go to the safe space of the
thing that they know and care about and
and that's
you know not healthy for the business
long term yeah yeah i think that's an
insight that so many people have only
only once they have started a business
yeah yeah when you realize oh actually i
don't know like
i guess i guess youtube is a different
example because you do actually make
money from it but like you know
just being good at making coffee does
not does not make me a good
owner of a or or manager or operator of
a of a coffee business
um
and so i first read the myth i think in
like 2019 or something and i had a
business at that point i've been going
for five years and i was like my god i
wish i'd read this book five years ago
because all of the mistakes under the
sun oh yeah and the first time i came
across that phrase that you know you
should be working on the business not in
it i was just like my mind was
completely blown and now it's just so it
feels so standard to me that i almost
can't remember a time where i didn't
know that that was a thing right and
even now when kind of coaching youtubers
and stuff this is the thing i try and
encourage more creators to think a
little bit more businessy because i
think creators are very easy at thinking
like oh it's about the craft it's about
the video i want to make sure it's about
how it makes me feel which is fine
but i also i think if you have if you
want to turn it into a business there is
a level of let's actually approach this
from a slightly more businessy angle
it's it's you know coffee
has historically had a difficult
relationship with profit because
you know a lot of uh specialty coffee
ran as a kind of counterculture to
commercial coffee which is coffee for
profit yeah right and so
uh when specialty coffee emerged it it
very much was like the it's not about
the money it's not about profit it's
about the coffee
and to focus on the money was not to
focus on the coffee and that was to
dilute the purity of what you were
trying to do and it made you something
of a charlatan or or or just someone
looking to extract
money from the system which is not what
it's about and you know the ethics of
coffee aside and the challenges there
aside
you know it took me a little while to
get comfortable with the idea of like i
need
profit to do the things i want to do
like it's the enabling factor in being
able to pay people properly hire more
people do more interesting stuff improve
what we do
you know however you feel about the the
model of capitalism aside
in this model i need to make profit and
good profit to have a sustainable
business
and that
you know i i think a lot of people
certainly in the coffee industry would
have heard the whole like you know you
need to make profit be like no no no i
need to make great coffee i need to find
my customers i need to build
relationships yeah but but what keeps
you going what builds a sustainable
business
is is an underlying profit
you can choose to focus too much on that
sure and you can compromise your product
but but they can be mutually beneficial
if you kind of do it right if you're
reinvesting if you're if you're you know
creating profit for a purpose
other than personal you know uh gain or
that kind of stuff yeah because i guess
profit is often seen as a bit of a dirty
word it is in many situations right like
lots of terrible things are done in the
name of profit absolutely like loads of
big businesses do terrible things for
for the benefit shareholders for to
maximize profits and i think that's that
i'm uncomfortable with that but at the
same time you know we end up in this
very binary sort of world of black and
white the profit is good profit is bad
well it's sort of it's sort of agnostic
of that what you do with it can be good
or bad i think yeah but this shouldn't
be the kind of shame that a lot of
business owners have around making money
in order to do good things yeah that's
how i feel about it you know i think i
got very interested in the idea of
sustainable businesses
you know because i how do you build a
business that that uh exists
outside of the people that work within
it
um and and this in coffee is a
particular challenge because
go back to this and i'll promise to make
sense of it you do loads of barista
training as a coffee roaster and a
supplier you train loads of people and
what you end up feeling is that you're
just pouring water into a bucket with a
hole in it because you train a bunch of
people they leave because they're just
there for a little bit and
the business itself doesn't retain the
knowledge and you look at businesses
that are hundreds of years old how did
they
how did they exceed the will or the
ideas of one person and become this
thing where they are almost a living
entity themselves and you get into the
boring answers of like systems and
structure and you build a business that
is able to retain knowledge independent
of the people that work within it and
that isn't a bad thing that doesn't
strip people of their value or utility
that makes their job easier more
enjoyable because they can still access
that information and knowledge but when
they leave
half your business doesn't work out yeah
that for me became a very uh interesting
sort of thing to think about of like how
do you treat it like a a thing that can
learn independently right can you teach
a business and we got really interested
in this with a bunch of customers like
okay we need to stop just training your
baristas we'll keep doing that but we
need to work with you in a way of
collecting and systemizing the knowledge
that we are delivering so that it's
yours regardless of who's executing it
and that sounds dehumanizing but it but
it i don't think it is i think it's it's
about creating actually a much healthier
environment uh for to work in where you
don't feel like you you can't leave
because you'd break the business that's
a really and a lot of people have felt
that way of like i can't leave when i
want to i want to do something else but
i feel stuck here because i know
too much of this company rests on me and
that's an awful thing to do to someone
it's not good retention that's a bad
it's a bad thing
so yeah i i think not enough people talk
about that the idea of like
you know be it a founder or key people
or you know the business itself has to
retain information knowledge it has to
have a purpose bound
into it
to be sustainable long term we are going
to take a little quick break from the
podcast to introduce the sponsor of this
podcast which is curiosity stream if you
haven't heard by now curiosity streams
is the world's leading documentary
streaming subscription platform founded
by john hendricks who's the founder of
the discovery channel and on
curiositystream they've got hundreds of
really high quality high budget
documentaries covering all sorts of
things from science and technology to
history and ancient civilizations to
food and medicine and meditation like
all of this stuff in between now the
really cool thing about curiosity stream
is that they support independent
creators and so there is this service
called nebula which you might have heard
of it's an independent streaming
platform that's run by me and a bunch of
other creators and on nebula we can put
content like videos and behind the
scenes and long form longer form stuff
without worrying about things like the
youtube algorithm and so for example in
nebula i have a bunch of exclusive
content that you won't find anywhere
else we actually have the original
season zero of the deep dive podcast
which started off as like remote zoom
live streams during the pandemic and
that is only available in nebula you
won't find it anywhere else so if you
enjoy the sorts of conversations we have
on deep dive you might like to see you
know a whole year before we started this
podcast properly once the pandemic
stopped what sort of conversations i was
having with people on zoom i've also got
a series of videos in nebula called
workflow which is where i deep dive into
some of my favorite productivity tools
and on nebula you also get early ad-free
access to my videos and videos from a
bunch of other creators that you might
be familiar with like thomas frank and
tom scott and legal eagle and lindsey
ellis and the really cool thing is that
because curiosity stream love supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiositystream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than fifteen dollars
a year you can get full access to
curiosity streams incredible library of
documentaries and also free access to
all of the stuff on nebula bundled with
that so head over to curiositystream.com
forward slash deep dive to get the
bundle deal so thank you curiosity
stream for sponsoring this episode yeah
i think this is again one of the one of
those things that you only really start
to appreciate once you have a business
and before
uh when i was reading about businesses
system structure processes hr values
vision what the hell is all that
[ __ ] and then as soon as you start
like oh okay now now i see what's
happening now i see why i like
it's you know with with my first
business it's bad that i'm i am the one
staying up until 12 at midnight making
sure that our book deliveries for our
course which is happening in manchester
tomorrow have actually arrived because
i'm the only one who knows how to deal
with the supplier that's probably bad
probably right this is figuring out all
these things like oh my god like what
started off as
me enjoying teaching courses for medical
applicants now turning into it to
turning it into a business is actually a
lot of the quote boring stuff which then
at least for me became the fun stuff
when i realized how much there was to
learn and how much of a kind of uh what
the learning curve was like and that
every new book i was reading i was just
my mind was blown like oh my god
businesses have been solving these
problems problems for decades after
hundreds of years there is a system
behind this and i can learn the system
um yeah i think that's the that's the
off you know i think for me though i
read loads and loads of loads of books
but there was still the kind of lag of
the conversion of information to
knowledge through the the application of
it you know i mean like it took me doing
it messing it up doing it again messing
it up to kind of get to the point we're
like okay now i truly understand the
ideas here and and how they work uh yeah
yeah it's like it's all it's all well
and good to read a book about hiring but
until you've done it and made mistakes a
bit yeah absolutely and you know like uh
you know i come from i suppose a family
of entrepreneurs so i was fortunate in
that i had
in my family people to be like hiring is
going to be the hardest bit uh
you know
all the advice they gave me i was like a
little bit blase about the time
it's going to be really hard starting
business is really hard like really hard
got it great and then like a year and
you're like this is really hard why
didn't you tell me and they're like
what's wrong with you uh and then like
hiring is going to be
the hardest bit and it stays the hardest
bit forever and you're like matt how
long could it be in the first stop we
had a really great first few people yeah
and i'm like this is fine this is easy
and you're like no no no no you learn a
bunch of awful lessons and and um
you know it still remains the hardest
part and and
especially if you want to you know i i
think that
there are
businesses out there that still want to
find a human extract the value
on you go yeah you know i mean that's
not that's for us not that interesting
we're interested in development enjoying
where you work satisfaction all of that
kind of stuff you know it's the the
slightly trite line of like we want to
be the place where you do your best work
but i think that's very true for what we
certainly aspire to but that obviously
it doesn't make things harder it just
changes the challenge and changes the
sort of focus
okay so let's go back to 2008 you're
27-ish years old bish ish thank you
deciding i've become world barista
champion i'm going to start a coffee
shop yeah what's like the dream there
like
is this going to become the next costa
the next starbucks is it gonna become
like independent pro like
what what's going through your mind to
make you decide you know what starting a
coffee shop is the way forward
i often think about the staggering lack
of long-term thinking that i had
and how that might have saved me
multiple times
um okay i think
you know we had when we started the
company we had a five-year plan
that was kind of revenue based
like we want to get to this kind of
revenue and if we get there in five
years that'd be really super successful
um and we'll be really happy with that
and and that would be it and we'll do
that through
wholesaling more coffee and i think that
once we focused on coffee roasting and
not coffee shops because economy tanked
forget about the shop there's roast
simpler lower overheads they become like
a b2b service almost super b2b service
super just providing roasted coffee
beans to right starbucks up until
the pandemic we were still 80 b2b as a
business okay um
and then obviously that changed
i've never once had the dream of i want
to become a you know a coffee roaster
selling coffees to companies i don't
think many people have like people have
a dream of starting a coffee shop but
not a dream of becoming a coffee roaster
i think sure but i mean most people how
do you good people dream about coffee
generally it's a weird industry no one
has aspirations people aspire to work in
wine or you know whiskey or i don't know
a bunch of my friends want to start
coffee shops or bakeries or restaurants
right they don't have a social space but
no one says i want to supply flour to
two bakeries they think i want to start
the bakery yeah but if you get a bit of
a sickness for
wheat uh and grains then yeah i could
totally understand how you would want it
okay so you know if you really get into
flowers for babies it's the industry of
wheat you understand a lot about that
can you get into provenance and flavor
and terroir and traceability and taste
of place and all of these things that
can totally suck you into ingredient
obsession
when you're a layman you want to make
the shop when you're a pro you want to
make the product of that
i don't think it's i think you know it's
a different sort of obsession or a
different sort of passion i guess
um
so okay so what we wanted to do super
early doors is we had been part of this
global culture of specialty coffee that
hadn't really kicked off in london you
know it
we maybe talk about this later i had
been part of it online for a number of
years and i felt part of a global
specialty coffee community but didn't
really exist in london back then there
was like monmouth had been going since
1977
and there was like a little place called
flat white and soho and that was sort of
the beginning and end of coffee in
london in 2008. that's unfair to a
couple places to pimps in the suns and
so but
there wasn't much for a city of 8
million people it wasn't much and so our
goal
was not to sell loads of coffee our goal
was to foster a community of specialty
coffee in london to help drive the
consumption of like a of good coffee
right we wanted great coffee to be part
of this city's
experience and dna you know so we named
the business square mile because
between 1650 and 1750 london was the
greatest coffee drinking city in the
world it had a totally unique culture we
had more coffee shops per capita than
anywhere else in the world we had this
really unique
culture here and we didn't in 2007
we had the americanized italian version
of coffee but we didn't have something
that was london's coffee culture and we
wanted to sort of help foster that and
we did that through working with cafes
and and you know that was the route that
we did it
uh and so yeah we we kind of grew as a
wholesaler and our our job was to give
good ingredients and and help
coffee shops succeed because if they
succeeded we succeeded they sold way
more coffee so did we so we were
motivated to do a good job with product
and then in our customer relationships
you know to help them win that was the
goal and if they won great and and that
also meant helping competitors win if
they didn't use our coffee
more shops meant more culture rising
ties little boats kind of thing very
true with coffee shops back then um so
yeah that was the kind of goal
how how much was culture of the main
like we want to develop this coffee
culture versus i need a job to make
money uh
so i i was necessarily early days it was
community not culture was the thing we
wanted to bring people who felt weird
about coffee together and then you know
what i mean like make them coherent
um we figured that was a great way to
grow the business
but also it was what we wanted we were
people who were weird about coffee who
wanted to find like minds and
it was a really strong really coherent
community and the advantage of that is
that if you are a deeply passionate
person if you're a lone voice you go
right at the back end of the news right
before they do the summary again with
the hey check out this one weird person
he's really into
i don't know water bottles and he's
gonna you know he's really into it and
here's this weird person yeah i'm
running into water bottles and you're
like how is how nice is that how
hilarious and they treat you as the one
lone obsessive
but
back then like magazines like timeout or
that you know the newspapers would would
talk to the one
crazed person about coffee who'd then be
like you've got to go and talk to these
five other people and then talk to them
and they talk to those five other people
and it made the sort of the voice
the voices of the community much louder
and more coherent and suddenly
the media paid much more attention to
coffee because there's this coherent
voice of
coffee can be good yeah if it can be
better coffee could be interesting and
that really supercharged london and
london just exploded compared to most of
the rest of the world it had you know
density it had enough money
but it also had this really coherent
community and london led the world for a
little while in terms of coffee culture
everyone was caught up i mean melbourne
was way ahead australia all that sort of
stuff but london had this really
interesting explosion certainly in
europe or also the northern hemisphere
that made it a focal point for a lot of
other places
okay question on that front um
when when you're starting a business
like now that you've done this i think
like a few a few times and you've been
in the in the game for for a while
uh
it's it sounds like you had a vision or
a mission that was bigger than just i
want to make money sure um in that you
want to create this coffee community
um how important do you think it is if
let's say someone wants to quit the job
and start a business today for them to
have a wider altruistic somewhat vision
behind it that's other than
i need a business to make money because
i want to try and quit my job and do
something that's fun if they wish to
derive satisfaction from the work they
do i think it's essential
because earning from i mean for a
certain sort of mind just just
extracting wealth is satisfying they see
the number get bigger and that's
satisfying enough but for most people
it's it's quite hollow and empty and
unsatisfying and they end up doing work
they don't like because the number goes
up but they don't feel good about it and
they look for something else so i think
having a purpose or a meaning behind it
for me is essential like what am i you
know i mean i i i don't really believe
in legacy
but i i think it's a shame not to to
leave something better than you found it
that seems you know what i mean like
the decent thing to do so i i want to
improve things or be have a positive
impact and so that's driving a lot of
the decisions i might make around
starting businesses or doing stuff like
that and i would say the people who
enjoy their work the most
i've met miserable billionaires you know
what i mean like miserable people
because they're just what the number's
very big
so what now slightly bigger like what is
that that is you know they're just
miserable uh i have no aspiration
for that um
so yeah for me i think it's essential if
you want to enjoy the work you do and
feel like it has meaning and purpose
yeah there has to be vision nice and is
this how you were feeling in the early
days as well or is this something a
philosophy that's developed over time
that's a good question i i think um
like uh
uh i'm i'm aware that i grew up middle
class and so i grew up with a safety net
in that i started a business and i was
never going to go to to zero you know
what i mean i think that that's
always worth noting in people like me
who took risks started businesses there
was a safety net
i was going to be okay and i you know i
mean that that changes your relationship
with money i think if you don't have a
safety net
then i i'm much more open to the idea of
like no i need money i need to build my
safety net because i don't have one um
but but i was aware i did and so for me
you know i was a very passionate person
about the product i just really i really
enjoy coffee i get very excited about it
and so that was always a driver for me
but i also like learning stuff and so
you know learning to build a business
with satisfying learning to sell or
market or do the other things that went
alongside that some like with youtube
now like learning to shoot better films
uh do better audio light properly all of
those things i enjoy that process that's
just part of
me i like the the constant obsession
it's just it's just very satisfying to
get better at something i like that i'm
always going to like that this is what
it is
um so yeah i i think i wasn't super
money focused i didn't earn very much
from the business for a long time
and and
um
you know
even now i i think my my
because we've always been bootstrapped
so the coffee company's bootstrapped
everything else has already been
bootstrapped
i have
left it in a lot of the time like i i
like uh especially going to pandemics or
going into whatever the economy is going
to do now
having
cash inside a business is a good thing
to me and that's just because i don't
like to be responsible to other people
because i suppose i have a bit of a
control freak aspect to me uh
and it's not like i'm against investment
or i'm against
you know
raising money in different ways but i
just like the control
it's just how we've always done it like
we've we've done everything out of cash
from the beginning and you would argue
and i would hear you and say you're
probably right that was not the best use
of that money
that we could have
you know uh borrowed leveraged the
business a little bit borrowed a ton of
cash grown faster done all those things
but if the goal is the goal is to make
better stuff and feel good about it then
that was not a route we needed to go so
so yeah like uh historically i you know
we can talk about money i guess a bit
i've never really pulled tons out of the
business which is
maybe foolish you know what i mean i
never really cashed the chips in so to
speak but i you know i'm interested in
the businesses that i work with doing
the work and being
long-term sustainable so so yeah that's
been the general approach interesting
yeah there's a
a good book by uh matt mccree the the
great ceo within um one of the things he
says is that because he he does a lot of
coaching for like uh tech founders
silicon valley types um and he says that
basically people want to go people want
to work or start business for three
reasons to make money to have fun and to
help people
um and but if you ask them that if they
could only pick one it would be to make
money
at that point once they've ticked that
box if they could only pick one it would
be to have fun generally and once
they've ticked those two boxes at that
point people then shift to
to the the helping people thing and i
think that's certainly true for me um
like it's it's very nice that right now
the thing that i'm doing does all three
um
but i think yeah when i was starting out
i was like you know what affiliate
marketing selling t-shirts on the
internet i'll do whatever i can to make
money
then it was cool i'm making money now do
whatever i can to have fun while doing
this and it's only kind of now that i've
done it for a few years that i'm now
shifting to actu to realize this point
about how having a wider mission is
ultimately the thing that makes it most
satisfying yeah i think i think purpose
is kind of everything for me and the
the bit you know i i suppose i've
have enough time to look back on whether
we're 13 years old or whatever else like
the
it's the same it's ultimately it's the
same as youtube metrics like subscriber
counts are deeply unsatisfying hitting a
million subscribers isn't rewarding in
any way not not a single way it's it's
it's
you know it's coming deep down when it
happens and then you're like oh yeah but
it really doesn't feel like anything uh
and it's the same sort of thing for me
in business is the same sort of thing
like like a big fat balance sheet at the
end of it sure good fine whatever it's
it's an indicator
same as an audience you could do
something with it if you want to but
it's what you're gonna do with it that's
more interesting more satisfying than
the accrual of the
number so let's go back to um
coffee roasting business just getting
off the ground uh
just again because i'm totally naive to
this space if i decided tomorrow i want
to make the alibaba coffee roasting
business
what what does it take to make a coffee
roasting business
that's like very very broadly we're
talking like what what's the cost of
yeah like the capex of going yeah i
guess like how much would it cost to get
started and what do you actually have to
do
yeah do you have to go to like colombia
and buy coffee or uh
you probably shouldn't um
that's complicated we won't go too far
down that rabbit hole but no it like
there's a lot of coffee tourism that
happens under the guise of buying but
it's really oh anyway what about fair
trade like i guess
you would need a coffee roaster a
machine that roasts coffee they
will depends how big you want it to be
um
per the old metric used to be per kilo
of capacity would cost you about a
thousand pounds that's now like 2000
pounds so if you want a 15 kilo roaster
that's probably 30 grand um and so this
is roasting 15 kilograms of raw coffee
one coffee at a time in one go yep to
turn it into those nice brand beans that
you see in the coffee shops indeed
so so that's the sort of the biggest
capital expenditure is probably the
roaster if you're in london you probably
need to treat the smoke coming from the
roaster because no one likes that so
that might
be another
10 through 20 can be quite a lot more
yeah oh what does that make the smoke
less bad for the environment yeah we you
either sort of reacted away or in a feat
of pure elegance you burn it
uh
okay
yeah we burn smoke um
which is
net better than
in terms of greenhouse emissions
burning smoke is better than just
letting the smoke out because there's
things in the smoke that are very bad
worse than carbon uh carbon dioxide uh
but yeah it's it's not you try and build
them as efficiently as you can but yes
you have what's called afterburners that
burn smoke and owning these is the
dumbest thing you'll ever do but it is
what it is um
are electric roasters i think electric
but they still produce smoke and it's
the roasting of coffee itself as it goes
brown
smoke is a byproduct so there it's it's
inevitable the bigger the roaster the
more the smoke so you need how big is a
coffee roaster like if we wanted to make
one here
how about what like a 15 kilo roaster
would occupy this sort of space of this
rug so it's not huge oh uh pretty big
like yeah it's hard to fit into bedroom
like a slight hustle business yeah yeah
i did once go to someone's uh
uh brooklyn loft conversion and they
somehow managed to get a 15 kilo roaster
into their uh
yeah which is highly illegal uh but it
was pretty impressive um
anyway uh
so you need you need roasters where to
treat the smoke you need um machines to
package coffee at least to weigh coffee
you can have to have fancy packaging
just buy bags and put coffee in but you
need to weigh it properly uh and
probably like beyond just a measuring
scale
you it would need to be trading standard
certified you'd need to you know i mean
if you're selling by weight at some
point you need to prove the weight to
the weight buying a scale on amazon
using that is not adequate for trading
standards unless it's properly
calibrated and you have a calibration
process
it happens now and again that roasters
don't pay attention to calibration and
end up selling you 230 grams instead of
250 that's illegal uh you're
who you'd report them to oh and they
would investigate they probably wouldn't
if it was a mistake they probably
wouldn't but you know obviously that's a
very cheeky way to make money you can
short someone a product they're probably
not going to check you know i mean when
was the last time you checked how much
granola came in the box you probably
don't
know like my 50 grand bag walkers or
whatever it is right you know there's a
lot of trust there um
but you know you need some kind of
special calibrated scale and thingy so
you can take the box of regulations you
are doing this thing um anyway that's
very boring i'm sorry
this is interesting like it's i i find
it so interesting getting an insight
into bricks and mortar businesses
because you just don't hear about them
like no one talks about what it's like
to own a freaking coffee it's really
true so starting in 2008 all of the the
startup stuff and i didn't know what a
startup was actually i i you know i
didn't know what how is that different
to a normal business i would see this
word startup i'm like what exactly is
this data
uh it's a question i feel like no one's
really good at answering yet either but
um
yeah i i was trying to start this coffee
roasting business and all of the books
were about
online startups yeah everything was
about when i started i was like no but i
mean how do i what is what is my model
like how you know you know no one would
tell me how much money to make no one
would tell me how much is a appropriate
amount of money a profit what's the
model you know what i mean it just
wasn't out there which is very
frustrating yeah which i i guess is kind
of unusual because you would like bricks
and mortar businesses have been going on
for loads longer than online businesses
right but i mean it was it was but all
the stuff is written by the online
business owners and of course and
the videos and the podcasts the whole
shebang it was all about that stuff it
felt weird i felt like you know but what
i will say is that that um
bricks and mortar is satisfying in a way
that digital is not a lot of us
uh
the day could be summarized into i have
slightly less digital stuff now than i
did earlier this morning and i'll have
more tomorrow because all i've done is
write emails today
jeremy like that that's that's i sent a
bunch of emails is like i have slightly
less in my digital to-do list
if you've manufactured a wall of coffee
that you're going to sell for more money
than it costs to make it
that's quite satisfying here's the thing
i made it i packed it myself i sealed
the bag i weighed it out i put it in a
box i sent it to someone and they paid
me and i made money on that because i i
created value as part of this process
that's rewarding in a way that that um
i struggle to find the same level of
sort of manufacturing satisfaction
videos are different because because
it's different but um certainly other
jobs or roles or you know that there's
been less you know yeah i guess being an
affiliate marketer
you don't really see that
yeah a tangible output of the thing that
you're creating and for a while i you
know when i was doing more office based
stuff as the company grew occasionally i
would just want to go down and pack
coffee for an hour because
that felt more satisfying than the seven
hours of staring at a laptop um for me
you know what i mean and that's just you
know anyway so
all the way back to a coffee roaster 15
20 15 to 30 grand for the 15k 15kg
roaster uh another 10 to 20 000 for the
weird machines that purified actually
say another 20 30 of like stuff
equipment for packing coffee
you're gonna need computers and stuff to
run stuff and then ultimately i suppose
you need raw material yeah where do you
go where do you get raw coffee from
initially you buy it from uh importers
so they are there are companies out
there that source this stuff bring it in
where has it in the uk and you can look
at a shopping list and be like i'll have
one bag of that one bag of that two bags
of this and one bag of that a bag being
60 to 70 kilos of the kind of jute sacks
and you would need to for your first
order probably buy 10 bags of coffee
about 700 kilos how much that cost
for half five grand probably
so this is not the the this is the
business that requires large amounts of
upfront capital right in fairness a lot
of bricks and mortar businesses yeah
absolutely and and you know we the great
lesson from my point of view is that we
didn't start with enough um because i
worked out too many
yeah so i fell for the the classic
what's the can i swear here yeah oh
great um so the hero [ __ ] of
entrepreneurship of like i almost grind
myself down
i'm a [ __ ] hero working super hard
i'm doing it right and it's such
[ __ ] and it's such a toxic aspect of
all work and i hate it but i definitely
worked 110 hour weeks for like months
ground myself down to the point of deep
misery and there is no
quicker way
to hate a thing you love
that than to work like to work on it
like that right like i really love
coffee i definitely got to the point
where i was like i should quit coffee i
should just i i hate this i hate this i
hate my life i hate working in this i
should just do something else because i
worked in a stupid way and i burnt
myself out physically and emotionally
because people do that because the world
says good for you get the grind on you
know i mean what it's your thing it's
yours pull yourself into it you're like
no don't don't do that that's really bad
what you should do is start with enough
capital that you can hire people to work
with you pay them properly
and then work in a healthy manner do you
know what i mean like just have work and
home uh be separate that's helpful turn
off don't work at weekends or don't work
some days a week it's very satisfying
early doors to to pull yourself into a
business it is rewarding it's enjoyable
but
you're just burning through yourself so
fast and so i regret not starting with
probably twice as much money hiring more
people out of the gate and going home at
five o'clock do you know what i mean
like just be done just turn it off turn
off the go home enjoy life you can build
this thing you don't have to sacrifice
yourself for this
the downside is you need more money to
start with so that's that's the
trade-off
we didn't have that money we didn't know
we needed it we had enough to buy the
physical things not enough to build the
systems hire the people and so we just
worked ourselves to the bone and it was
miserable and i regret it and it was a
mistake oh
okay
on that point so
i feel like
sort of
at least in the online
online discourse around starting
businesses circa 2013 to 2019
was the era of the hustle culture
movement saying that look you're
starting from nothing your 20s are for
hustling you've got to grind yourself to
the ground work on weekends work on
evenings to make that to start that
thing
since pandemic i think has accelerated
this there's a lot more like
that kind of approach of actually
sustainability is important etc etc
um but what a lot of the kind of
pro-hustle people say is that like
when
when you don't have that startup capital
like
and you're working your crappy job and
you need to start the business there is
not much you can do other than kind of
work between i don't know 7 p.m and 2
a.m and also work on weekends and all
that kind of stuff and i guess you're
just hoping it's just a season of time
so that you can build enough money build
a business off the ground because it
will take blood
theoretically it takes blood sweat and
tears to get a business off the ground
from from moment one
um
and a lot of entrepreneurs that i've
spoken to who have done that kind of
were grinding themselves to the ground
say that yeah it wasn't ideal it wasn't
really a happy time but without that
period of crunch which for several years
potentially the business wouldn't have
gotten off the ground so i guess my
question to you is do you think that you
would have been able to do it in a more
nice so sustainable way or do you think
it was necessary to put in the blood to
get this get this off the ground i think
i think that the tricky bit is that if i
had had the understanding that i have
now
and a little bit more capital then yes
we could have built the same business
far more enjoyably i don't think it had
been a bigger business necessarily but
it would have been a more enjoyable
process to to do that and i think
certainly
you know i may start more businesses in
the future
and and i know that i got a little bit
hustly when youtube started to kick off
for me and it you know i mean i was like
oh i got to feed this a little bit
because you know he feels when you when
it feels like you're pouring just
straight gas on flames and that's just
every everything you put in comes back
10 times you're like
quite addictive yeah but it then you
still end up with a well where are you
going with this like what's the yeah all
the big questions yeah yeah it doesn't
you might get to where you don't know
where you know you get to a point
slightly quicker but what's the point
you're trying to get to
do does it need to happen quicker is
that better
um so you look i i'm not saying that
there's a perfect way right like to to
back in 2008 to raise another 100 grand
would have been really hard you know the
the the the the system that we live in
makes it much easier to raise 1 million
than 10 grand
we can get a 10 grand bank overdraft but
i feel like if you go and pitch big and
you make big promises yeah you can raise
lots of money on the on the promise of
lots more later but if you want like a
10 grand overdraft please the bank's
like no
yeah you're like i turn over like 30
grand a month and they're like uh-huh
and you're like 10 grand you know what i
mean like pre-financial crisis you could
get like a month's turnovers overdraft
was the sort of rule of thumb yeah and
post financial crisis the banks were
like nah uh which is really unhealthy
for for loads of small businesses it was
it really restricted access to capital
from 2008 probably to 2015 was really
difficult right
if you wanted less than 100 grand
the moment you wanted serious cash to
make big promises to to roll out this
giant thing that little ipo or there'll
be an exit much easier i mean for a
while i could easily raise it two
million quid
in a way that i couldn't raise 200 grand
that's what that's messed up but that's
that's the way it was back then it still
is now reminds me of that quote which is
that um i think you you probably come
across it that um
uh if you owe the bank 200 000 it's your
problem if you owe the bank 200 million
it's their problem absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely a weird weird system of
capitalism but that's what i mean like
it's messed up you know um
but yeah so so you know i i'm perhaps
talking about this idealized world where
i could have found another 100 grand
somewhere in a way that that didn't you
know result in me signing over uh
control or or direction or or you know
what i mean some aspect that would be
later important but i do know that had
we accrued more capital at the start we
could have worked in a way that was less
damaging to our physical and mental
selves yeah and and you know i i think
you can justify culture all you like
i i just i i don't think i'm proud of
those years the way that i worked i mean
am i proud of where we got to yeah maybe
sure but i don't like that that was the
the root and i certainly wouldn't wish
that on anyone else and i would wish for
or encourage a a system or a way of
working that wasn't that
i mean like i i would hope for other
people you know i don't feel like i
suffered you should suffer too that's a
sickness that affects our culture i may
i suffered i would like you not to
suffer because this sucked uh that's
sort of my feeling about life
so yeah i'm not saying there's a perfect
way it's a messed up system but that's
my experience and how i feel about it at
the end of it so i guess okay so let's
say if we if we could rewind 13 years
and you have the same understanding you
do now but you're in those market
conditions yes it sounds like you
probably would have spent more time
trying to figure out how do i actually
raise the startup capital i need such
that i don't burn myself out rather than
oh can't read a hundred grand
you know there's always other things we
could do if we knew the value of it but
i guess
at the time when you're at that stage of
life you're like oh i'll just i'll just
work harder
yeah that's absolutely it and certainly
the the the everything around me told me
that was the right thing to do
you know what i mean that was the the
culture around entrepreneurship was yeah
yeah you work you can put those out no
one else can do it for you it's your
business
get out what you put in
uh and i believed it and but i i do i
don't
you know i don't want someone watching
this to hear me say yeah you should
hustle yeah you should suffer
you know what i mean i i don't feel
comfortable saying those words to
someone were bits of it fun
yeah lots of it was fun like it it was
it was growing we were part of this
booming thing like um
you know
we felt um
like we were making an impact you know
what i mean like we felt influential
that was very satisfying we felt like
you know what i mean like we felt like
we were pioneering in some ways that
feels very
arrogant to say and awful but it felt
that way at the time
it's not really a phrase you get to use
about yourself
uh but that's how it felt it felt like
we were kind of pushing new ground and
it was people were excited about it
and i think that we were
having a wider impact and growing more
than just our business
so yeah that was that was good
yeah because i think
this is the
kind of conundrum i find myself in
sometimes with this business and the
team that we've got here where
like it's very easy for things to feel
very frantic that oh we're doing all
these things we're launching projects
and if these are a thing let's get on
that you know abcdefg and
like
you know the other day i kind of just
got a bit of an impression that everyone
was just a bit like
sort of working flat out
and i kind of stopped and took a step
back i was like why the hell are we
working flat out here like this is a
this is supposed to be calm the reason i
left medicine is because i didn't want a
life and death job
i didn't want something that was like
massively stressful right so why are we
creating these can these like
constraints for ourselves where we have
to be wedded to oh this course needs to
come out in q1 because 31st of march is
an arbitrary deadline that we have
decided and if we push it back two weeks
that's the end of the world and
therefore we have to burn the midnight
island i think without a it's when you i
i guess you know our team's very young
average age like 27-ish when you have
like a youngish team of people who are
you know hungry and keen and hopefully
enjoy the jobs it's very easy to
unchecked it sort of to
turn into this flywheel of
for a sort of frantic franticness and
stuff and it needs a bit of a
moderating influence like a coolant
to be like hang on let's just actually
think about why we're doing this yeah
you know are we all happy broadly happy
with how much money we're making and to
the extent that we're not on the poverty
line poverty line yes cool so then
chasing more and more for the sake of
like i don't know an extra
an extra dose of revenue or profit or
whatever
at the risk of sacrificing our mental
health and burning out and stuff
probably unsustainable let's
you know that's excellent yeah
i think it's i i think it's back to the
idea of you know
your best work does not happen in that
environment you know what i mean like
yeah you might occasionally pull out
something from the bag under pressure
but
constant pressure
yeah no no one does their best work like
that you know what i mean like you need
space you know like uh
you you need to just have for everyone
needs a little space in their work i'm
just like i'm not
i can have time to think and read and be
bored briefly and those things are
really important really useful
especially in creative work so going
back to
our roasters so we've contacted one of
these wholesale suppliers of like raw
coffee beans needs to be roasted
now you have a wall of coffee beans that
needs selling yes
what do you do then do you go to
starbucks email.com and be like hey do
you want some coffee like how does it
work no i don't know you by lines you're
going to sell to independent businesses
starbucks already have their own system
starbucks roast their own coffee they've
got a massive facility in the
netherlands that supplies most of like
europe and
uh
western europe now i don't think anyway
um so you you're probably going to sell
this either online which is one sort of
challenge or you're going to sell to
other
coffee shops and i think it was a little
bit different when we started but but
these days
it's back to to having a bit of a
problem in that most people who start
coffee roasting companies are very
passionate about producing the best
coffee they can
and
so they'll
think that because they have what they
believe is better coffee that's going to
be quite easy to sell
but the problem is that if you go to a
coffee shop and you say hey
i've got better coffee one you're saying
the the coffee that you have chosen to
serve so far is
not very good and two that's probably
not fixing a problem that a business
owner has right like sales is solving
problems to me and so
if you think about what problem a coffee
shop might have
better coffee probably not one of them
actually like they've probably already
chosen coffee they like and so why would
i buy your better coffee than you know i
mean
why would i buy this yeah if it's not a
problem people aren't going to pay to
solve it like exactly so then you're
into okay well what what do you do
that's different and and that's a much
more complex thing and that's also why a
lot of small coffee roasters struggle to
grow because they don't have a
compelling answer to uh a problem that a
cafe owner might have
uh but yeah that's that's that's what
you're gonna do you probably quite early
get stuck in the trap of credit where
you might say oh you you're gonna let
someone get the coffee and pay you 30
days later oh yeah that's a standard
thing isn't it like invoice terms and
accounts receivable and all this yes
that normal businesses non-online
businesses have to deal with and and
that historically has come from larger
businesses leveraging capital to gain
customers of like what's the problem the
coffee shop's got not enough cash flow
great let me solve that problem for you
if you sign with us this binding
contract to buy coffee from this for 12
months we'll give you 28 days from
invoice so you'll order coffee through
january we'll send you an invoice
february 1st and on the 28th of february
that coffee is due
because we've got enough cash that we
can lend you this much cash and you've
got loads of time to sell that coffee
make the money
and have a bit of cash flow back okay so
this sounds good and bad yeah what are
the i guess the good part is that you
can then get the product without paying
for it so for the coffee shop it's great
i can i can get
500 pounds worth of coffee in the door i
can sell that turn that into ten
thousand pounds obviously i'm gonna pay
wages you're gonna pay rent all the
other stuff but i get a chance to do
that before i have to pay off the bill
for 500 at the end of it
that's the that's the upside then also
however i'm a bit stuck because i can't
buy anyone else's product because they
won't give me the terms and i'm spinning
agreements so essentially they've bought
my loyalty but they've solved a problem
for me which is cash flow and that's a
very common problem in you know a
business that you know coffee shops have
big fat quarters
you know
big big bad quarters so they'll often
have a large vat bill at the end of each
quarter to pay to the government yeah
and then that wasn't the cash flow right
it's often a cash flow issue for
businesses that don't make large margins
and aren't occurring a lot of cash at
the bottom so having suppliers give you
credit terms essentially gives you
liquidity
the problem is that if you're a small
coffee roasting company
it's very easy to get into that and then
coffee shops well they often fail uh and
okay
at that point if they go into
administration
you you know best case from liquidator
might be 10p on the pound kind of thing
of your your debt if you manage to get
to the top of the pecking order of like
who's getting paid out by uh those which
you won't so you're getting nothing so
there seems to be a straight bad debt so
you've given them the coffee you said
they promised to pay you 60 days from
now right but in that 60 days they go
bankrupt
and you've already given them the coffee
right and that well you can't do
anything about that classic this happens
all the time loads of bad debts out
there and chances are actually you
probably kept they they they've already
missed the payment february 28th i'm
like no no we'll get it to you and get
it to you just keep sending us coffee
we're sorry we messed up we forgot to
write the check or someone messed up or
whatever other story and so you might
get 90 days of product to that customer
and then they go bust and then you're
out that much money
if you're a giant coffee company ah
cost of doing business it's built into
the price it's fine if you're a small
independent coffee roaster we haven't
built that margin in because you try to
be competitive with pricing uh
you can you can have a five or ten grand
debt that would take you down two
because that might be your cash flow
gone and then you know historically
we're always taught bricks and mortar is
like
a profit is one thing cash flows
everything
right like if you don't have
you go under because you run out cash in
the bank not because you weren't
profitable but you ran out cash in the
bank
because certainly you know we got we
were never not profit we were always
profitable but we got real close on
running out of cash because you do if
you're growing you know the roast is
buying stock buying bags we're not
getting the same sort of terms so we're
laying out much larger invoices we've
got you know say 100 grand of stock
that's cash out we've got all these
other outgoings and we're still waiting
for money coming in and there's
profitable money coming in but there's a
gap yeah and so
you know
that doesn't exist as much in the online
world but but bricks and mortar
businesses cash flow is the main concern
which is why credit is such an appealing
way of of selling
coffee
uh so yeah that's the sort of that's the
the bit that
you create quite a fragile market and
certainly you know right now there's a
lot of debt in the market you know i
mean there's lots of businesses that are
struggling for cash that will owe money
to suppliers
and they'll owe money to fruit and veg
suppliers milk suppliers take away cup
supplies coffee supplies and they're
hoping their restaurant for coffee shop
or bakery will do well enough to be able
to pay those to make it through that's
quite that sounds quite hard from that
from their perspective as well like yeah
it's incredibly stressful yeah you're
like always running in the red and at
the end of the month you're like oh my
god we just need to wait for tomorrow be
like oh but the person paying our
invoices off six so we can't we can't do
payroll this month right or we can't
afford payroll yeah we don't have to
capture the bank for payroll and then
and all the employees are like well i
need to pay my mortgage right i'm not
coming to work if you're not going to
pay me yeah yeah yeah it's
you know it's yeah then this but this is
a reality of a highly competitive yeah
old industry it's been going a long time
it's developed certain bad habits and
certainly i think credit is one of them
um
but i mean that's again further
encourage people to underprice product
you know coffee is probably too cheap uh
but you know it's it's as cheap as
people can make it and still just about
survive that's kind of how pricing ends
up being in a highly competitive market
which isn't in anyone's best interest
long term but it is what it is yeah so
how did how did square mile succeed
despite all of these
i think initially it was a different
sort of
approach
our problem early doors was like people
aren't really drinking specialty coffee
and people didn't really know how to
build businesses doing that and we had a
background of teaching and training and
education and like we're going to help
make you successful our goal is not to
sell you beans our goal is to make you a
successful cafe and we'll work with you
on your training programs we'll work
with you on equipment or anything else
but our goal is way more than just
selling them coffee yeah yeah yeah
that's just that's that was our approach
and
everyone's problem is i'm not successful
enough yeah so if you're focused on like
we're gonna increase your top line yep
aim to increase your bottom line too
somewhere in there you buy some coffee
but but we're trying to
help you build a better business that
was our initial kind of goal and you
know it's changed over time and you know
at some point if you have a more
recognizable brand the problem you can
fix is my customers don't trust me
because i'm a new coffee shop and the
answer is if i buy a brand of coffee
that they do know they might trust me
they see the logo of ex coffee company
like oh this is probably good coffee
right that solves a problem it's a
difficult problem because other brands
solve the same problem it's not as
effective
but but yeah i think that was always our
approach of like we want to help our
customers succeed
it feels disingenuous now like
you know i did all the sales early doors
it's very easy for me to talk about that
time i don't do the sales now and you
know i mean like it feels like i'm
speaking on behalf of people which is
you know i i i don't want to minimize
their job
more complex kind of talking about early
days where but yeah certainly early days
that was our kind of approach and i
think we had some experience in what
great coffee was and i suppose i had
this weird title to be like well i know
what good coffee is because i'm on the
stupid dog show uh so so like you know
that's that's how that went
okay so the way you you differentiated
yourself in this crowded potentially
crowded competitive market was not
not actually competing on the quality of
the coffee but in fact being like the
whole the service as a whole where we
help you be a better cafe solve the
problem that you're having
and by coincidence by the way we also
sell some of these things yeah kind of
yeah i think so it was designed to be a
more collaborative relationship
and not just his box here's my check see
you next week
uh so what's happening with the
square mile these days
well it's you know uh it's been an
interesting couple of years uh yeah
obviously when when the first lockdown
came in
we you know 80 of our revenue stopped uh
because every cafe shut initially well a
handful is dead open but almost everyone
shut because that was the thing to do
and businesses shut down
and uh i think we were very fortunate
that over the years clearly people had
developed an attachment to our coffee
through the businesses they were buying
it from because
when when
b2b disappeared online exploded
and so we very rapidly transitioned into
being very focused on
you know we were aiming to be good
online already but suddenly there was
just a bigger market for that and i
think we had a lot of growth and that
was
you know something that we worry about
quite a lot in that it's been a really
busy successful two years
and that's definitely put a strain on
people inside the business and i think
you know like um our focus for this year
is not rampant growth in terms of top
line or any of that kind of stuff uh
it's a kind of it has to be a year of
consolidation and i think a year of um
making a stronger company and a stronger
company is not necessarily growing the
top line at all costs a stronger company
is looking after the people inside it uh
making sure that they enjoy coming to
work are not exhausted by the process i
think we all have like a
a layer of fatigue globally from the
pandemic like this there is a i think
everyone feels fatigued by it all is
that fair yeah do you
you know i think that impacts everything
uh
just it's been draining it's been
emotionally draining and physically
draining for lots of people and that's
regardless of where you work or what you
do
and i think you can't ignore that fact
when i think if you've been successful
in that time and you've had that
then i think it's maybe
the temptation would be now we've got to
go harder again and harder again and
harder again and i'm just not sure
uh i think we're not sure that that's
the right way to go and i think we want
to build a healthy strong company
because again we're interested in
sustainability we're not working to an
ipo we're not working to an exit
we're just trying to do what we're doing
do good meaningful work but sustain and
last you know
so it sounds like square miles kind of
go from 2008 to 2022. yeah to say things
seem to have gone pretty well with
pandemic transition to to online and
stuff
when did the other stuff that you do fit
into the timeline that's a really good
question so i've so
you know i sort of took on a de facto
managing direct role in square one in
the early days we didn't really think in
those terms but i suppose i did those
kind of things um
and i have also worked with other
companies as a kind of collaborator in
terms of designing or promoting
equipment and those kind of things and
so by 20
i want to say
2013 maybe
i was like early 30s
yeah traveling enough 2013 2014 i want
to say i was traveling enough that we
realized that if anything
inside the company was reliant on me
being in the building
it's broken
because i wouldn't necessarily be in the
country i was in melbourne for a month
at one point i was traveling all over
the place like it was just a lot of
travel a lot of away time and i i think
that the dual factors combined of
the kind of person who might be good at
starting a company
is not necessarily the kind of person
who's good at running
uh a small medium-sized company
i don't know you know what i mean we
were initially a small company and then
we got to be a big small company and
then yeah how many people are we talking
about in square one now is about just
under 30. okay um
but but but i think that the role of
running a business changed and i think
it wasn't
what i was very good at and again i
wasn't always there and i think they
have a broken system yeah right that's
bad so i stepped out of the managing
direct role and a new managing director
stepped in she'd been with us for a
while
very capable and she runs the company
still
uh and we began to work out how that
relationship would work and be healthy
for both
the company and specifically actually
for her in that role uh
you know if you talk to a lot of
founders who
um in theory move out of operations
they often love a medal they love to
come back set some fires
and leave right and so we you know we've
tried to learn other people's hard
lessons the easy way yeah and so really
early doors were like how do we stop
this happening okay jeremy what are the
ground rules of how i interact with the
company now that i'm not operational um
do you not have a thing of like okay so
i i have this problem where it's all
well and good trying to get other people
to to do stuff and then you see
something that you think
this seems dumb why are we doing it that
way and then you start meddling
yeah yeah but i'm not allowed okay
that's the deal right that's the deal i
i i i it if i want someone to take on
this mantle and to work with me and then
be satisfied by the work i have to let
them do the work and and it i have to
move into a more passive role
of how am i useful to you
right but it's a yeah sure there's times
where i'll i'll i'll be like i have to
be in my body about something and i'll
be like talk into the office can we talk
about this and but that's the first
point of contact it's not me going to
the person in the role and being like
can you just go and do this because i've
seen this and i want this and do that
yeah i did that a little bit in the past
i get told off good because i shouldn't
be left unchecked because
it creates a really difficult dynamic in
a business
because
ultimately i'm a founder and if you're a
founder there's a different sort of a
relationship you have if you work in the
business the founder walks in the door
that's different right and so
it's easy to accidentally override or
derail the direction
that the managing director is is
dictating correctly
don't mean to be like what you know i
it's easy to come in like oh i was
thinking about this the other day and
you can set someone off on a task
for a week
and and you know
then at the end of the week eventually
direction is like so where are you with
this and i'm like oh i'm way over here
and you're like why are you over there
because we're going over here well james
said
and that's really unhelpful that just
that's a company working against itself
and that's bad so the rule is very
simple i can be called upon by the team
yes if they want something from me they
can take something from me yeah and that
might be ideas for
marketing that might be ideas for
products that might be
knowledge or specific things or whatever
it's going to be
but anything that i wish to inject into
the company has to go through the
managing director at an appropriate time
we'll sit down and talk about my ideas
and then those that that are deemed
worthwhile yeah can then be taken in
further but i am not allowed to come in
and give direction to anyone in the
company about anything that's the deal
that we made nice and that's because i'm
saying you're in charge of this company
i have to mean it yes otherwise they're
not and that it's just a very i'm not in
charge of the thing i'm i have all the
responsibility of running this thing but
i'm not actually able to steer the ship
because someone's got their wheel on it
and they keep pulling it to the side
every five minutes i'm trying to go over
there and they've just had a moment of
like but i want to go here quickly yeah
it's unhelpful and i think it's bad i am
not perfect in that regard but i try
really hard and we talk about it a lot
and we make sure that that we are
constantly aligned because you just
can't have the bit of like well
you said this but she said that yeah
which one do we believe which is the
truth really unhelpful right if i'm to
be useful
then i have to be a resource i have to
be passive and i have to be
respectful of what i've asked someone to
do in that role of running the company
and which is please let me run the
company if you want me to do the job let
me do the job that's the deal
uh so i guess you need quite high
confidence in that person that you have
hired them to run the company they are
competent but they also should be
comfortable saying i need a little help
with this yeah or i'm not sure of this
and and you know like
the person i speak the most to in the
company is the managing director we talk
a lot about everything and it's just
great for me to feel connected and also
for her to have a sounding board and and
you know another person she can talk
freely to about any aspect of the
business
that's that's a good healthy
relationship i think without a business
and i think it allows us to be very
coherent and it just stops me setting
fires
i i want to don't get me wrong like i
see stuff and i'm like i just want to go
and meddle with that but i know the deal
and i can't have it both ways it doesn't
work jeremy and i can't have the freedom
so to speak yeah of the responsibilities
and then all of the fun meddling that
just that that just breaks the thing
might be fun for a year but it breaks
the thing yeah
meddling pedaling i have so much stuff i
wanna ask you about this more but i
think we're getting we're getting into
weeds that is not applicable to most of
our show so if i can take it back so
when when did the youtube channel start
and how did that fit into your whole so
i
pretty much i blogged early days i
started blogging 2004 i felt very
isolated and alone in my coffee
obsession and the internet was full of
people enough people that i could
connect to you know like it's like a
healthy version of flat earth right
where like i was the one
isolated person i really love coffee and
no one else cares uh but the internet
cared and so i i started a blog to sort
of chart what i was learning to to you
know go through the classic process of
if if i understand it i can explain it
to someone right so and in sharing it
with someone else that's valuable so
that's why i will write this blog
and the winner of the blog uh which is a
bit like youtube i kept doing it and i
just kept doing it and for years and
years and years and years and years and
years and years i kept doing it and
blogs
came and went
uh but i sort of was consistent
throughout and consistency
has this really fascinating value and it
wasn't that i blogged every week i
wasn't seth godin doing every day like
you know it was i was just regular i
kept going and and
it made it more rewarding for me and
also more valuable and and
as a thing however by
2016
people have moved from blogs to video
and i'm a little i feel late i feel late
actually 2016. uh like casey neistat's
exploding at that point during me like
and i'm like i should drive i guess i
should start on youtube i guess you know
um and i knew people that would do like
starting to spend money with influencers
and i was like what's good is there an
economy here i didn't really know about
no one takes youtube very seriously at
that point
outside of people already in youtube
that makes sense so yeah 2016 i started
uploading videos which were initially
like
um i i i bring up nice that because you
know it like
it was a really
easy uh
thing to copy yeah right and so
distinctive style that's very right i'll
do like i'll do like vlogs but i'll do a
weekly vlog i'll cut out my week
you know put some like head nodding hip
hop in there and you know what i mean
i'll do that and i'll try and work out
how to do that and i did like 12 weeks
of that i guess
i was like okay actually i you know
i wanted to develop a practice
of making videos but these aren't the
videos i particularly want to make like
i'm not actually interested in sharing
my life that much i'm interested in kind
of communicating with that and really
early days i wrote a blog post about
takeaway cups and how they're not that
bad and what the actual impact of them
is and i made a video about them and and
like time on site on the blog it's like
a minute and a half on average it did
like i don't know 10 000 views
and then back then that video did like
15 000 views on youtube with like a six
minute
time assignment like all the attention
is on youtube it's on video and so if i
want to communicate with people if i
want to learn and share and teach
i have to move to video that's just what
it is and i've made little videos in the
past and i feel like i liked it but i
wasn't very good at it back then so i
started making videos on youtube and you
know a couple of really interesting
lessons early on for me was that
moving audiences between platforms was
almost impossible however many
subscribed like 20 000 followers on
instagram and i could not get them to go
to youtube i was like but i'm making
videos and they're like yeah we like
instagram uh same with twitter same sort
of 30 000 on twitter
couldn't get anyone to go to youtube
yeah and you've got that initial
audience through the blogging through
just being what the initial effect i got
to 2000 quite quickly and then i
flatlined for a long time and it was
really like you know it took me a long
time to get to 10 000 subs from that
point onwards and that's the club that's
youtube right like it's just the graft
and it's just it's a it's a difficult
place to be discovered it takes time
you've talked about this a lot it is
what it is and that was again totally my
experience too so
yeah um
i think by 2019 i crossed the hundred
thousand subscriber mark three years to
get
um that's great yeah i'm not i'm not mad
about that no that's interesting because
i think i think i think i think people
have a lot of like unrealistic
expectations
about youtube like you see the big
youtubers and often they're the ones
that sort of broke out earlier on yeah
and then i find you know we have
hundreds of students going through a
youtuber academy every cohort and people
are always like oh i'm on video number
32 and i'm still only on like 3000
subscribers like bro take me 50 videos
to get to get my first thousand like
what are you talking about and even you
with with that inherent unfair advantage
as it were of being a world barista
champion of running a coffee roastery
business of like being very very pro at
this thing talking about the thing that
you're pro at still took three years to
get to 100k damn yeah that's great i
love that but you know it
took me a long time to get better at
making videos to understand how to you
know i've done a lot of presenting over
my life i've done a lot of talks on
stage i did you know in in the in the
job my first kind of um
training job on with the commercial
machines that was a lot of presenting
essentially it was two two hour talk i
would give several times a week so i got
comfortable
presenting which is a whole other skill
that i i guess i had a lot more practice
at coming into youtube than is normal i
guess which maybe helped a little bit
um
so yeah that that that took a while i
had a few videos do really well but but
you know the way that you know it it was
interesting to me that
um
weirdly coffee is a part of some
people's lives and coffee is a part of
loads of bloggers lives and vloggers
lives and you would see a lot of people
have a little coffee part of the the
videos but actual coffee content on
youtube there wasn't very much and quite
early on on national coffee day like
youtube's twitter account was like go
and watch james
and i was like wow that's cool but also
you don't have many choices this is a
really empty niche it's changing very
quickly now uh as the sort of niche
fills in inevitably
but that's good that's really helpful um
so yeah like um so yeah for the first
three years it was like i had a little
space
um
that i used for making videos and also a
sort of office near home
far enough away that it was
healthy yeah but still convenient and
then that was a bad studio and it was
sounded awful and slowly we sort of
improved that and then it kept going and
going and it sort of gave momentum
um and for a long time it made no money
and i it took me a long time to discover
that i had somehow at some point
unticked a box
on adsense that was like the the
essentially there's a box of like can
google serve people custom ads to who
they are and for some reason i don't
check this i have no idea when i checked
it but basically google couldn't serve
tailored ads which meant that my adsense
was appalling uh
really like appalling uh for the views
that i was doing i was earning like a
fifth of what normal adsense would have
been for those kind of things i don't
really know but the point was i had a
job
i had a living and this was like a thing
that i was doing because i was
passionate about teaching and sharing
and communicating and doing that kind of
stuff and then it grew and grew and i
was like okay now this is a business and
i have to sort of switch my thinking and
this
to being a business now and and i still
struggle with that
part of it because my
my instinct is to try and build a
sustainable thing
and you're constantly wrestling with
youtube of like
when when do i hit the top of the bell
curve when am i gonna see the decline
how do i build a sustainable thing but
then you sort of listen to other
channels
i think marquez has been particularly
interesting on this front he's just like
no i'm just going to build a production
company in an inch in in a sector that's
always interesting and we're just going
to go yeah and you're like oh maybe
that's because i part of me is like okay
this is this is am i going to be a
youtuber in 10 years yeah i think about
this all the time i don't know
but but i'm genuinely enjoy making
videos and and producing them and
sharing them and doing this kind of
stuff so i'm like maybe i want to do
this in 10 years i don't i don't know my
career has taken so many weird routes
and you know like i've done so many odd
things as part of the stuff that i've
done i i'm very bad at predicting the
future so two years feels like a long
time to be predicting for
but yeah so now i'm trying to understand
how to build this into a sustainable
thing
uh what that is what that looks like how
much time i spend doing that like i have
quite a condensed work week probably
more so than most people would think i'm
sort of
for various reasons i probably get
everything done that people see me do in
about 25 hours a week and then i have
other stuff the other part of the week
uh and i try and sleep but whatever um
but yeah 25 30 hours is my kind of
active working time in a week
um
on this sort of stuff and and the
subtangential stuff of that as well you
know this sort of advisory work that i
do or other things that are
off topic
um so yeah i'm trying to work out what
what what you know it's better the ideal
day what do i want
a week of making videos to look like
what do i want a day to look like i've
always enjoyed
having no structure to my life it's just
easier uh i don't have any routine i
don't know what i will do tomorrow i do
tomorrow but i mean tomorrow i'm gonna
get a plan and go to italy that's not
normal so you know like uh you know
there's no rhythm
and i'm sort of okay with that to some
extent i've lived that way for a really
long time now
so yeah
now youtube is a thing i have to pay
attention to it and i feel a
responsibility with it you know what i
mean like i feel like i
especially as a large creator in a small
niche
i have a disproportionate
influence i think is unfair and
inappropriate but that's the nature of
having a loud voice in a relatively
quiet room
um so that stuff stresses me out a bit
but um
yeah mostly i just like i i like making
videos and i think i have ambitions to
be better at that as well as
the stuff inside them i just i don't
know do i want to be a director
no but also kind of yeah
anyway yeah so what does your overall
like business portfolio as it were look
like you've got youtube channel you've
got the roast story did you have other
stuff going on
um
so
like what
lots of them aren't income if that makes
sense i don't take anything from them at
this point okay um what are the streams
of revenue then
sure revenue revenue is probably fine uh
so square mile is one square mile owns
most of a cafe called proofrock
um which is another business square mile
also uh
well we sort of have an investment in a
espresso machine distribution company in
the uk they so i collaborate with the
manufacturer in italy
and i've helped them design and build
and sell machines i haven't built them
but they've built them oh you've
designed espresso machines sort of i've
had input into these cool things
and so
that relationship has led to kind of uh
us beginning to import those machines
into the uk and then they've mostly
taken over that business it's a branch
office for them but we're still sort of
involved a little bit yeah uh in that
business this youtube and the sort of
bucket of youtube that is also things
like money from books
so i wrote a book in 2014
that continues to sell in a way that i
don't understand but i'm very happy
about uh it's one of those ones where
they sat me down early doors and i'm
like you're not gonna make any money
you'll have a beautiful business card
but you will not make any money and i
was like cool and then it's done like
three hundred thousand copies and
everyone's a bit like oh wow uh bloody
hell no i don't know i don't know uh and
that's interesting i've only recently
gotten into the publisher outside the
300 is a hell of a lot of copies but
that's what this is 2014. so it just
ticks it's just good in a way that's the
marquess approach to selling books it's
gone really well this is your atlas of
coffee there's the world house of coffee
yeah so just finished another book we
wrapped the photography on it last week
um little command august
uh can you say a copy of course uh of
course um
yeah it's just about making coffee it's
kind of the youtube channel as a book
yeah and kind of
fleshed out in a different sort of way
it's a book um anyway uh just
just on that gig so we shared the 300
000 number like
does that like how how how much do you
make on a royalty from a book oh very
little are we talking like pennies are
we talking dollars tens of dollars like
so okay so um
i think i might
i'll make less than a pound a book at
best okay
and often less than 50p a book and often
less than that because a lot of them
have been in translation instead of the
way the licensing of translation works
yeah because the alice is very image
heavy it's kind of cartography a ton of
licensed images
the the word component little piece of
the book and so the words don't earn
that much money right uh and that's okay
like you know over those eight years
it's been it's been
really nice to have that revenue come in
and it's money i never expected yeah and
it's been really nice um but yeah it's
not i haven't earned 300 000 pounds from
it uh which is you know part of me i
should write fiction uh that seems to be
much better children's fiction
yeah right
like that's the word
yeah i'm not gonna do that but um
so yeah no the book but the book has
been a great way to sort of
i i don't know the book was written to
be not about me which is kind of weird
there's my picture's not in the book
nothing about square miles in the book
it's it's built to be useful to anyone
interested in coffee and that could be
competing businesses to mine i'm sort of
i'm the name on the front and that's the
only time i'm really in the book is the
name on the front thing um and and
that's sort of the same with the youtube
channel obviously i'm not there to
advertise the coffee company because i
want to be useful
to coffee companies everywhere who can
be like oh you want to know about this
you can watch james's video about that
and if it's sort of apolitical that
works much better um anyway so that's
the book
i'm bouncing around a bit um
so yeah the book and sort of other sort
of uh royalties or other things like
that would fall into sort of the youtube
business um we have a merch business
separately called tens hundreds
thousands um that's one thing and then
there's a few kind of investments um in
some cases
uh i've started and sold some businesses
in the past and those have gone
different places and one of them um was
a kind of part cash part paper deal so i
have a little investment in one company
that bought a business of mine and they
have some investments in various things
i invested in um
a canned coffee beverage in uh san
francisco called taika who are kind of a
coffee and adaptogens in a can and it's
great it's just very good if you can get
it here it would be great i'll tell you
something
i will work with a danish booze creator
called empirical spirits who do really
interesting stuff uh there's a
non-alcoholic brewery in the uk who i
think are amazing called big drop a tiny
investment with them uh there is uh
someone else oh there's interesting
software as a service platform and
coffee um i'm working with a little bit
called beans who are doing interesting
stuff but really on like business to
business coffee stuff
and and a few other bits and pieces i
think out there
i'm not really an active investor in
that regard
but i i'm interested in seeing cool
businesses do cool stuff and there's
times where i'm like yeah okay i'd like
to be a little bit involved but i'm not
writing big checks you know what i mean
like uh there's little checks little
tiny checks um just because i think you
on a cap table is just evaluating itself
even if you only play to some businesses
yes maybe um you know and it's been
interesting to learn about that world
yeah uh
you know what i mean like uh most people
never have to worry what a convertible
note is uh and that's probably for the
best uh
if i'm honest you know like that term so
often i still haven't google defined it
you know what it means but sister and
then you get into like blind trusts and
like you know like the the whole deal of
um
preemption rights and dull things and i
don't want to get into this yeah i have
lots to learn about that particularly
yeah i'm not sure it's certainly not
something i'm interested in in deepening
my involvement in uh meaningfully
um
but yeah like that's the sort of sort of
i i i you know i run a very boring i
have a decent pension i have a little
bit of money in like a like a child
stanley ask kind of thing but i but i
historically i've just chosen not to
pull much money out of my companies and
so um
yeah that's been a kind of uh it's a
high paper net worth but not necessarily
a yeah which you know like um
yeah like a
i don't have a particularly extravagant
lifestyle or demands for one really yeah
you know what i mean so it i don't know
part of me is like you should get the
chips off the table the kind of deal up
together the gambling party is like you
know like cash out a little bit cash out
cash out but i'm like i don't i don't
know
so yeah like that's that's maybe not the
healthiest approach to money but it is
it is mine and and like i don't know i i
i'm not driven by accruing an enormous
amount of wealth because i don't know
what i would do with it i'd probably
aspire to give a bunch of it away or use
it help you know sensibly because i
don't i didn't want very much you know
what i mean uh
which is something i'll try and maintain
it just i don't know i see again i've
had interesting
talks with incredibly wealthy people and
and uh
they're not very happy miserable people
like a bunch of miserable people
and you know
that doesn't appeal to me just i don't
know i think you very easily get into
just make the number bigger and that's
the least rewarding game in the entire
world so that's i'm like how do i not
play that game
i don't know and i also think like
i think i think generational wealth is
important but i also think you easily
cross a line into just like
the easiest way to destroy a human is
give them an enormous inheritance i
don't think there's ever evidence of
that going particularly well so like
like i believe people should be
able to build generational wealth but i
also think there's this kind of points
where it gets a little screwy and i
think i don't know like
you know i was never promised any i was
given a safety net growing up sure but i
was never promised there's never going
to be like a you know but i imagine how
it must be to grow up and be like at
some point i'll have a hundred million
quid
i think that's i don't think it's good
yeah is that good i don't think that's
good i'm not sure that's good i you know
what i mean you can do with your money
what you want to do but i don't i don't
know if
giving an enormous amount of money to
someone
will help them lead their happiest life
i think about that quite a lot so anyway
a little bit like the die with nothing
thing right
yeah a little bit similar to that of
like you know i don't think you should
it's a world where you might want to
pass on enough that your kids get on the
housing market or you know i mean like
they can
get through university debt free and not
you know carry a student debt throughout
their entire life that's unnecessarily
stupidly crippling
but i don't know if millions of pounds
at some point is like good and healthy
question um one
standard well so somewhat standard piece
of business advice is stick to your core
focus stick to the thing that you're
good at your hedgehog concept your
whatever your unique ability et cetera
et cetera um
we've been thinking about this i've been
thinking about this a lot when it comes
to setting up a kind of merch company
sure so i was very inspired when you
gave a talk at the ziggurat summit a few
months ago actually yeah around how you
have this separate company ten hundreds
of thousands which does your merch as it
were but it's not like it's not like a
t-shirt with your face on it although
this would sell it's more like these
these cool products uh like the decks of
cards and and stuff like that
and i like the idea of making physical
products and in fact we have some
physical stationery which you do is
around here somewhere um
but i also see the advice of you know
the physical products are a bit of a
side hustle like i'd love to make my own
mechanical keyboard i'd love to make my
own everyday carry laptop bag just
because i freaking love keyboards and
bags and pens and journals and you know
the daily productivity kit
but it's not our core focus in that when
we as a team are not very good at making
physical products we don't have any
expertise in it and the thing we do is
content so one argument is double down
on the thing you're good at
there's another argument for
diversification for building a brand
outside of me necessarily that i can be
the marketing director of but not
necessarily the managing director of uh
or not so intrinsically tied to the
brand that it is unable to function
without me in the room um
but it's like yeah any any thoughts on
that balance between stick to what you
know and
do content around the thing
versus branch out into multiple things
where you might not necessarily be an
expert like physical products
sure i mean like i i
we do it because the actual creation
process is very enjoyable like making
fun new things is satisfying i think
that's why we do some t-shirts and
posters but we also try and do
more interesting stuff that's just kind
of
satisfying in that regard
um
you know
i i think the reason we kept it separate
is again it's that kind of part of like
how do you build a sustainable thing
i want it to have a relationship with
this audience outside of me i can do the
marketing for it in some ways that's
good but i i like the idea of it being
its own independent thing
that it can grow a team inside it can
have development for the people inside
that not it doesn't have to be huge it
doesn't have to turn over millions of
pounds it can do that
as a smaller business and still be
satisfying and at the end of it to be
like we made some cool stuff and people
really enjoyed using it and that for me
is a
probably a bigger motivator than it
generating
thousands of pounds of profit or payout
but that's just
you know
going into this because i've had a job
from the beginning
and this hasn't been lifeblood stuff
i've had a stronger feeling of like what
what's the thing i want to do that i
enjoy you know what i mean like
i i have no doubt that the essentially
stuff has been very satisfying for you
sitting down with it and using it yeah i
get to use my diary every day right like
that's that's that's enjoyable but that
doesn't make much money yeah yeah i
don't think we're at break even just yet
but still it takes time like um
but it's one way at the end of the year
that may be a moment that you reflect on
me like i've enjoyed that yeah it was
that was that was you know like uh that
was a return on whatever i put in i felt
a return on that and i think that's that
has its place i think
you know running around trying to do six
million different t-shirts and mugs and
all the rest of it can easily be a
distraction
it's not a great margin business unless
you get deep into the manufacturing and
then that's
building the manufacturing like you're
going to start a paper factory
there's a whole other thing you know
you'll make a lot more money on each
little diary yeah but you'll have had to
build a paper factory to do it like you
know that's the that's that's the
trade-off
um
so
you know yeah i i i think for me one of
the requirements of business is i enjoy
it i'm satisfied by it and i think this
is a great way to do that and again i i
think i'm also interested in poking
around in the places that people aren't
there yeah i mean like no one's really
making trays for dosing coffee and two
before you put it in your grind yeah a
lot of people are making t-shirts and so
the t-shirt real estate available to get
my t-shirt on a body is limited
uh
i mean like you're gonna have to pick
the and we still make them and i enjoy
them and we just have some fun with them
but like
it's t-shirts are not as satisfying as
like we've got a some botanical prints
coming like botanical drawings uh an
artist who works with cue gardens a lot
like
it's like legit botanical drawings turn
into like these posters i want to own it
actually like i
if i don't want to own at the end of it
we don't make it uh if i don't wear the
merch we don't make it if i don't want
to drink out of the mug we don't make it
like i have to want all of it and i
really want to own these prints yeah
because i love botanical drawings um
so we're going to make it and you know
like we can and why would you not if you
could that's that to me is the better
why would we do this because we want to
and we could we have the opportunity
like i think
switching to youtube for a second like
i'm in a weird place where
i can i have the freedom to make videos
that really no one else in my industry
can make
it doesn't you know i like i i uh from
adsense or patreon or other things i can
spend money to make videos
so i feel like i have a moral obligation
to make things that no one else can
because they don't have that opportunity
and i would be squandering the
opportunity to make stuff so that's what
we want to do like it doesn't i'm going
to fly to italy tomorrow because i want
to talk to someone who's the biggest
collector of vintage espresso machines
in the world like they have a museum
they are like the the person i want to
buy a vintage espresso machine and
ultimately i want to put it on bar in
london and have people drink coffee from
a machine made in the 50s and have like
a really that's a nice thing you know
what i mean but that's that's the
upfront cost of that and actually it
will lose money as a video but it
doesn't matter
i can do it i should do it then that
would be cool because i want to do it uh
that's a weird metric for making
decisions but it's very satisfying
that's a great thing about it
yeah if i think of the keyboard if i
think of the bag the stationary it's
like it's it's cool and i want to do it
and i know it's not going to make much
money but i think i need to start
shifting my thing from
the thing that we should be doing is the
highest roi thing to roi measured in
things other than profit yeah you know
it shouldn't be damaging for the
longevity of the business but you know i
think that yeah it's not it's easy it's
a nice metric
which makes it very appealing yeah but i
don't think it's always the best metric
yeah and i really like the idea for
example spinning this off into another
company that that can have its own team
that have ownership that have equity et
cetera et cetera so that it feels like
and you know i think it's it
the the model that you described sounds
like you are the owner of multiple
businesses but not necessarily operator
of multiple businesses and that i feel
very good at it yeah i feel interesting
i i think i'm kind of like you and i
like the idea of starting stuff and
shaping the vision initially and then
when it comes to the day-to-day stuff i
would much rather someone else deal with
that
yeah but you know i think it is
important to understand that that there
has to be a trade-off in that yeah and
that there's days
yeah there's days where i want
to get in the nitty-gritty and i just
can't you shouldn't and that's just uh
that's that's part of the trade-off but
yeah i think i'm not very good at a
bunch of stuff i'm quite good at certain
things and i think i'm most useful if
i'm doing creative stuff i'm kind of
good at ideas
and ideas are valueless uh without
execution and i'm not the world's best
executor so i need to work with good
executors to be vaguely useful to anyone
and um i think we we over
value ideas uh you know we sign ndas
around ideas you sign it's a nonsense
they're worth nothing until they're
executed upon do you worry about like
money these days
no
yeah i mean yes and no like uh
you know going into the current economic
future yeah
if we go through if we get into the
spiral of inflation and all sorts of
other stuff yeah that's concerning
that's a worry but um
yeah i don't i don't really
meaningfully wear i mean i've worried
about it in the past you know like i've
sold food sold
clothing items or vinyl to pay rent and
you know like uh
uh i don't worry about it the same way
now
but i'm i'm you know what i'm aspiring
for is just i want the brain space back
uh to think about other things um so
yeah i i think that's but that's easier
if i don't want a ton and i think if i
had a lot of i'm trying not to get into
the hedonic adaptation of of that stuff
where you just consume more compliments
with that stuff
again i'm desperate to learn other
people's hard lessons the easy way
and you you don't always you you you
intellectualize it you understand them
but you still kind of get sucked in and
then you know two years later you're
like oh no this is the lesson i need to
learn two years ago and i i can't learn
on paper i have to learn it by making
mistakes
okay so i'm i'm 27 right now probably in
a similar position that you were
probably a few years ago just getting
started with all this stuff not taking a
lot of cash out of the business because
reinvestment et cetera et cetera um i'm
noticing a tendency of lifestyle
inflation in myself where it's like you
know
a thousand pounds a month rent is good
but five thousand gets you a really nice
apartment oh i wonder what ten thousand
you know it's etcetera etcetera um we
were talking about espresso machines be
like oh i'd like to get into this as a
hobby and i know and and i see the
warning like the warning signs of like
hang on the more the kind of
uh baseline how much money i need to
comfortably live the more that increases
based on just hedonic adaptation and um
lifestyle inflation and stuff
the more worries about money i just will
have further down the line sure whereas
if i can actually be very comfortable
living a slightly more frugal life uh
keeping in mind the principles of diet
with zero then it would free up a lot of
head space because right now i spend a
lot of time thinking oh [ __ ] what what's
the business gonna look like three years
from now are we still gonna be
profitable i'm still gonna be a youtuber
et cetera et cetera any advice
just i think from that to you
it's really paying attention
to the dissatisfaction or the lack of
satisfaction that comes with spending
more money sometimes you know what i
mean like you buy the nice thing yep and
you're like
take a nice camera you buy the nice
camera like that is nicer
but i'm not satisfied and part of your
brain goes you didn't spend enough right
and so that's the answer is you can't
spend enough you're this feeling is
inevitable you cut you can't spend it
away so it's it's when you have that
feeling i think it's really useful and
nice but like okay that is
oh there isn't there isn't what i what
i'm looking for is not here in the thing
and i think i think a nice and not
picking on you so you buy a nice camera
but uh but i think that's a good example
of that like that that feels nice to use
and there's moments where it feels
special but it's left you feeling like
what do i get for even more right i
suspect yeah i'm like the q2 is nice but
like the lego q3 is going to be even
better because it's going to have a way
of recharging by usb or like an m
whatever that has film oh hello you know
yeah and it's
that's the wrong diagnosis of the
symptom you know what i mean and it's
just trying to catch yourself in that
loop of like oh i can't i can't upgrade
my way into a more into satisfaction
yeah i mean it it isn't there yeah and
and stop chasing it you and i mean like
uh
but at the same time lean into the
things that do give you real
satisfaction i really enjoy food i
really enjoy restaurants i don't want
you know
i think the fun thing about restaurants
is that
um
the really super expensive ones are
terrible value for money okay right you
can eat incredible the cutting that the
most interesting food is necessarily
most expensive sure if you want to get a
noma or you want to get the fat duck
that's that's an experience but i think
really interesting food doesn't have to
be very expensive but and that can be
satisfying it's discovery it's just
straight deliciousness you know what i
mean like that that i'm happy to lean
into and spend on because i find a
strong return on that
particular thing you know and and and
try not to fall into food as fuel or
just like whatever else that happens
because you've got stuff to do and i eat
at my desk like most people and that's
wrong and messed up uh but the trade-off
of trying to work more in less time um
so yeah that that that's a kind of piece
of it i think of just like where where
are you finding genuine satisfaction and
not just the that's good
i enjoy it
but
and they like that's a dead end and you
can go for you just it's a dead end down
there yeah the minute you buy the nice
thing and it's not quite what you wanted
and you want more
nah not gonna happen oh interesting yeah
i guess um
ramit sethi has this kind of idea he
talks about figure figuring out what is
your rich life like what what are the
areas for you in which
uh the addition of more money does in
fact lead to more enjoyment satisfaction
et cetera and it sounds like for you
being able to just eat at whatever
restaurant you want is a significant
value add yeah absolutely whereas for
other people
who are happy with like the local fried
chicken joint
that's not a thing that they should
spend money on because it's not going to
bring them any satisfaction but but i
think that's you know it's it's
understanding where your passion is kind
of intertwined like i'm a flavor person
you know what i mean so that's
unsurprising that i'm interested in food
and then
things like provenance and story and all
these kind of things get woven into good
food and good
there's not restaurants uh
of fried chicken nuts
but um yeah i i think that's it for me
and just like thinking about
budgeting for those things separately
but also understanding them well enough
to to buy them well you know what i mean
like i love food it doesn't mean i
should be spending 500 pounds a meal to
be satisfied that's a different that's
just a that's the wrong shortcut you
know what i mean what is your sort of uh
vision these days
in what regards because you said that
before you had the site this vision of
like building a community of coffee
lovers or equivalent and you were
agnostic about the details of the
execution sure do you have a similar
thing for like your life or what you
want to do personally
i think there's a bunch of
you know i work in a deeply
broken industry okay
coffee's messed up coffee is built on
colonial wealth extraction coffee is
ethically highly questionable it's bad
even if you're paying better prices
you're still working within a system
designed to extract as much wealth as
possible from producing countries and
and capture it and keep it in consuming
countries
that's not very good there's a massive
imbalance of power it's ethically highly
questionable and while we try and
operate within that ethically
it's a more extreme version of there's
no ethical consumption under capitalism
right like it's true
i'm i'm i'm very uncomfortable with that
being a part of my life and i don't know
how you change that but i'm interested
in working towards
coffee being a better industry
on my end i feel like i have an
opportunity to to have people see coffee
as being more valuable than they do
could the coffee industry spend 100
years teaching you that coffee was cheap
easy commoditized gets you caffeine and
a bit of bitter taste and it's fine and
that isn't true and i need people to see
it as being a bit more valuable
because they enjoy it more that's the
secret if you enjoy it more then then
you've got a bit more space to spend
money on it because it's rewarding and
you enjoy it so that's my
kind of raise on detroit for youtube is
to like have people enjoy coffee a
little bit more so they see it as being
more valuable
because coffee needs to get more
expensive
because it's just too cheap and it's
wrong yeah end of story uh and then i
have responsibilities further back in
the chain to how we buy and that kind of
stuff to do a better job but i don't
feel like i should necessarily lump
ethical challenges onto the consumer who
just wants a cup of coffee in the
morning if i get you enjoying it
delighting in it it's a very positive
experience for you then that's easy for
me to develop that relationship if i
just tell you you should feel bad about
yourself for buying coffee that again
dead end things a little bit so that's
kind of a thing so
i yeah
to make coffee sustainable coffee has to
be much more expensive that money has to
go to producers they need more power in
and more sort of equity in the whole
supply chain uh and at the end though
that means a more expensive cup for
consumers and i need them okay with that
seeing the value in that
to sort of have that happen i can't do
this on my own yeah but it's a role i
can play that's very cool
i don't know
feels tiny and pointless some days and
satisfying and wonderful in others and
that's just the nature of this
yeah it's like you're
not
being so grandiose is like i want to
change the world single-handedly but
it's like wanting to leave make the
world a slightly better place in your
own way where
you're kind of leaning into the things
that you're good at things that you
enjoy and the platform that you've built
therefore the opportunities and
privilege that you have to
make this
change happen
or work towards it i think so i think
that's a pretty good summary of of the
aspiration of the the project right now
yeah i think it's a good place to come
in the conversation thank you very much
for coming on i feel like we could we
could talk for hours and hours
it would be good to do a round two
sometime when we go more into i'm very
curious about the ethics of coffee we
kind of went a little bit into the whole
like nestle stuff which i still like
have so many unanswered questions about
um and i'd love to learn more about the
sort of more specific the business side
of things that you managed to
pull the strings of um but i think yeah
this has been great i think people will
get a little valley from the
conversation hope it was fun thanks for
coming along yeah great
thank you very much all right so that's
it for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye